a 61 year old woman has just given birth
to her own granddaughter who was
conceived by combining her daughter's
egg
with the sperm of her son's gay lover
meanwhile 76 year old former Vice
President Joe Biden is in trouble for
smelling teenage girl's hair on the
campaign trail we will examine modern
love with uncomfortable Joe Biden like
closeness then President Trump hits the
socialist nail on the head and National
Poetry Month continues I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Knowles
show
[Music]
it occurred to me as I was reading that
open about the 61 year old woman who
gave birth to her own granddaughter with
the sperm of her son's gay lover and her
daughter's agonal that sounded like an
Andrew Clavin parody open it sounded
like some of Andrew clavin's political
satire except it's not it's reality
because we're living in 2019 we will get
to all of that in one second but first
let us make some money honey with ring
rings mission is to make neighborhoods
safer you might already know about their
smart video doorbells and cameras that
protect millions of people everywhere
ring helps you stay connected to your
home anywhere in the world so if there's
a package delivery or a surprise visitor
you will get an alert and be able to see
hear and speak to them all from your
phone that's thanks to the HD video and
two-way audio features on ring devices I
love it you know J hey the senior
producer was able to talk to these drug
addled maniacs trying to break into his
home the other night at 3 in the morning
because they knocked on his door to
basically casing the joint trying to see
if anyone was home and he picked up from
his bedroom and said hey what's going on
and they scramble away he could have
been on a beach in Boca he could have
been at the office I love my ring my
ring makes me feel a lot safer it just
in my own place that's why I've
recommended it to my friends I have
given it to my friends this is the best
housewarming present
you're gonna love it as a listener
you'll have a special offer on a ring
starter kit available right now with a
video doorbell and motion activated
floodlight cam the starter kit has
everything you need to start building a
ring of security around your home just
go to ring.com slash an old scanner wles
that is ring.com slash Knolls KO wles
61 year old woman gives birth to her own
granddaughter using the sperm of her
son's gay lover and the egg of her
daughter why do I even know about this
story why why is somebody telling me
about this because this is being pushed
by BuzzFeed of course this is not the
first time that a grandmother has been a
surrogate for one of her children it's
uncommon you have to be in very good
health to
a 61 year old woman who can give birth
and act as a surrogate this isn't the
first time this has happened before
however I do believe this is the first
time that a grandmother has given birth
to her granddaughter using the sperm of
her gay son's lover and the egg of the
daughter here is how the piece begins in
BuzzFeed quote matthew eledge and Eliot
Doherty of Omaha Nebraska needed a
surrogate to carry their baby they never
expected she would turn out to be
Matthew's mother
first of all yes they obviously did
expect this because they asked her to do
it and the mother offer so they did
expect that it doesn't this doesn't just
happen like they're trying to pass this
off as though wow what a kooky crazy
thing AB you know I guess one night we
all got drunk and the next thing you
know my mother is the surrogate giving
birth to my daughter that is conceived
by my lover and my sister that doesn't
just happen this was all very planned
out this isn't just some kooky weird
little natural thing that happened this
was schemed and planned out and it's a
very terrible thing also it happened in
Omaha Nebraska who saw that one coming I
was just in New York for the past few
days I was giving a speech in Jersey you
might expect that sort of thing to
happen in New York New Jersey San
Francisco lala land you might Omaha
Nebraska that does worry me we're
talking about the heartland of America
this sort of thing happening there not a
great sign for the culture I'll spare
you the two thousand word article or
whatever it is here are just some
highlights we're very very lucky Matthew
said even so Matthew and Elliot's road
to Parenthood hasn't been without
obstacles as other LGBT parents around
the country and particularly in Nebraska
can attest but the couple wanted to
share their story in part to prove that
a family like theirs can thrive anywhere
even in the conservative heartland of
the u.s. the language is the issue here
we'll get we'll get to the facts of it
in just a second but the language is
what would I really take issue with this
is the the BuzzFeed language the popular
left-wing language they never expected
this would happen of course they did
they planned it all out Oh their road to
Parenthood hasn't been without obstacles
you don't say to men trying to be
parents together that's not without
obstacles I can think of one pretty
major obstacle that would that would
make that difficult of course it's with
obstacles what are the obstacles what
are we talking about by the way what
road to Parenthood if you were to skim
over this article you would think that's
Eliot and Matthew conceived a child
together you you would get that
impression
obviously it's that's absurd that is not
possible for two men to conceive a child
together but you you might think that
because it's the road to Parenthood but
they overcame those obstacles on the
road to Parenthood and now their parents
not so that is not so in the in reality
in a biological sense the biological
parents of this kid are Matthew's sister
and Elliot who is Matthew's boyfriend or
significant other or gay marriage or I
don't I don't know the precise
circumstances there's a mother and a
father here the problem is the mother is
out of the picture and this obviously
creates significant moral dilemmas that
BuzzFeed is totally ignoring totally
running over the piece goes on they talk
about how it's very expensive to do in
vitro fertilization to bring in
surrogates to do this you have to pay X
amount of money and and Matthew says and
that is literally the cheapest it could
have been said Matthew each cycle of egg
retrieval and transfer can cost about
$12,000 which the family only had to pay
once since Cecile the mother got
pregnant on the first try
or the grandmother I guess plus they
didn't have to pay tens of thousands of
dollars for donated eggs since Elliot's
sister Leia donated them for free listen
to this clinical language when we think
about the miracle of life when we think
about the miracle of life as a metaphor
for as a real metaphor for the love that
moves the Sun and the other stars when
we think about what when kids ask a
mommy and daddy where do babies come
from what's the answer what is the
cliche answer
well when a mommy and a daddy love each
other very much a baby is produced and
that's actually the best answer you can
give when a mommy and a daddy love each
other very much in a very literal way in
a physical way they love each other they
make love and then in a spiritual way
the child this child which is body and
soul body and spirit is the spiritual
product of that love as well now listen
to this description each cycle of egg
retrieval and transfer costs a lot of
money but luckily cecile got pregnant on
the first try and they didn't have to
play pay for donated eggs because Elliot
sister Leia donated them for free she
didn't donate anything she's the mother
who is producing a child that she will
have no accountability toward no
responsibility for no more of a
relationship with than she wants than is
convenient than is comfortable for an
aunt she a false relationship to pretend
to be an aunt when you're really a
mother that sort of language how
dehumanizing how yucky how I think there
is a good phrase in the bioethical
community that leon kass used very much
but the bioethicists leon kass who said
that there is a wisdom of repugnance i
don't care who you are I don't care how
liberal you are how left-wing how
progressive how forward-thinking how
LGBT LMNOP friendly how all of these
thing you read that there is a certain
spiritual repugnance that you have
toward this there's something that you
read you say gosh that's just not quite
right it's just not quite right for a
grandmother to give birth to her own
granddaughter which is really who is
really the product of her daughter and
her son's lover there's just something
not quite right about this what's not
quite right it's it
sometimes difficult to articulate but
especially for people who consider
themselves very progressive very
open-minded very forward-thinking
but we know it's true
we just know it deep down now we can
articulate this the trouble is if we
oppose something like this
we are maligned as haters they say you
hate gay people where'd you get that
from where'd you get that idea from
you hate sought your anti-science
no well no I Sciences science Sciences
knowledge sciences creates technology
and some of that is good and some of
that's bad and some of it's neutral and
it can be used for good or bad things
and some things are good and some things
such as this or bad because what is not
mentioned in this article what's not
mentioned BuzzFeed totally overlooks it
is the victim here all of these crazy
scientific experiments produced a
daughter who is being intentionally
deprived of her mother
Elliot sister Leia donated the eggs for
free no she's a mother who all of you
schemed schemed about and created a
child a daughter in particular who will
not have a mother-daughter relationship
with her own mother because of your
selfish desires that is very bad that's
a very bad thing that's the victim here
Oh she'll be fine no the kid will be
raised fine yeah I guess probably I
don't know maybe maybe the kid will be
raised just great well a child it would
be better for a child to be raised by
two gay parents than two good gay
parents than too bad straight parents
yeah okay maybe maybe that's true sure
but that's not even really what we're
talking about here we're not talking
about a child being adopted two good gay
pair really nice caring compassionate
gay parents or really bad awful terrible
straight parents we are talking about
intentionally producing a child who will
be deprived of her
because you and your boyfriend want to
have a child even though that is
biologically impossible
and so you scheme you contrive every way
using modern science and modern shallow
incorrect moral philosophy to say we're
gonna use the sisters kind of like the
brother so we're gonna use that egg and
that it's kind of like it's the daughter
of but not quite and then we're gonna no
one wants to care so we'll use the
grandmother to carry that there was a
meme that was going around the internet
it said future genealogists someday
looking at this family tree and it's
just that video like jiff of that
comedian is uh uh uh what uh cross-eyed
looking all crazy there are consequences
too there are other people involved it's
not just about your desires and I don't
just mean to inve against this gay
couple and the strange grandmother and
the thoughtless sister that's not there
they're not the only problem here this
is a broader problem of designer babies
of an inversion of the natural order
which is that we have children to give
our love the love that created us the
love that created everything around us
that gives us life we pass that love
along selflessly to a child we don't
create a little designer baby because
you feel that something is lacking in
your own life that is utterly selfish
that is utterly opposite of the natural
order of giving life and creating
children be getting children also
another victim that of course BuzzFeed
isn't going to talk about here are the
ostensibly additional frozen embryos
embryos that are either frozen or
destroyed because when you do IVF as as
matthew eledge says here it's very very
expensive so usually what you do is you
fertilize multiple eggs so you create
multiple little embryos you create
little individual human lives and then
you implant one or you implant three and
then one takes and you take kill the
other four or you just freeze a bunch of
them either way you're creating multiple
individual human lives
and then either destroying them or
freezing them suspending them in time
those are victims too and moreover
justice is a victim here it is that is
wrong to do that is selfish to do that
is taking what should be the ultimate
act of selflessness begetting creating a
child and inverting that and making it
all about yourself we're only gonna see
this continue we're gonna see gene
editing technology we're going to see
much more of this in the future that's a
scary thing because we no longer possess
a vocabulary to discuss difficult moral
issues and difficult bioethical issues
as we begin to think of people as just
flesh as just meat and bones and yeah
what if I put these two things together
sister's egg lovers sperm put them
together put them in the mother's womb
who you know whatever okay it's all just
flesh right the more we think about it
that way the more we will be unable to
discuss bio ethical questions because
we're not just flesh as Winston
Churchill said when great forces are on
the move in the world we learned that
were spirits not animals the destiny of
man is not measured by material
computations and as material
computations take over and base and
selfish desires take over we're going to
have a much more troublesome destiny of
man to look at speaking a modern love
can't forget about creepy Joe creepy Joe
Biden getting hit from all sides
you know I'm defending him I'm still
defending him on the argument but
politically it's very difficult to
defend him here's a great attack ad that
just came out from one of the pro Trump
PACs on poor old creepy Joe it happened
also suddenly very unexpectedly
out of nowhere I feel a Joe Biden put
his hands on my shoulders get up very
close to me from behind
lean in smell my hair and then plant a
slow kiss on the top of my head to have
the vice president of the United States
do that to me so unexpectedly and just
kind of out of nowhere it was just
shocking it was shocking because you
don't expect that kind of intimate
behavior you don't expect that kind of
intimacy from someone so powerful and
someone who you just have no
relationship whatsoever to to touch you
when to feel you and to be so close to
you in that way
oh that is a juicy attack ad that's a
really good attack ad so I'd like to
make two points here one I don't think
Joe Biden has really done anything wrong
what Joe Biden is is an unctuous
politician who goes out and presses the
flesh to use a particularly vivid phrase
and his whole shtick is he just seduces
voters right mean that's what
politicians like Joe Biden do they go
out and they have their nice shiny teeth
and that smile and they go up and they
say you know you you're great I really
care about you and they're flirting but
it's in a it's in a not a romantic way
we have never heard a story about Joe
Biden getting an apartment in DC well
he's a senator and bringing his
mistresses all around and we've never
heard that story what we have heard is
that Joe Biden is a little weird and
he's too affectionate on the campaign
trail which is true those are different
things the second point I want to make
here is that this is a great political
attack this is a terrific political
attack and if I were running against Joe
Biden I would play that video all day
long because it doesn't really matter to
voters whether he's some sexual predator
or whether he's some CAD or whether he's
some womanizer or if he's just kind of
creepy and he's it just does
look good I'm cam right there's no
difference in the mind of voters and so
absolutely if I were running against Joe
Biden in the Democrat primary I would
use it against him if I were running
against him in the general election
which will never happen cuz he's not
gonna get that far I totally would use
that against him the other day Donald
Trump used this line about Joe Biden he
said I was in Iraq I was talking to the
generals there I said I love you so much
I just want to kiss you I felt just like
Joe Biden you know he's just music Joe
Biden has become a punchline
that's why what he's done is politically
indefensible Joe Biden cannot afford to
be a punchline this early on bado right
now is fighting the same exact thing
some candidates have avoided this Kamala
Harris is not really that much of a
punch line yet Sanders actually is not
really that much of a punch line yet Liz
Warren is a punch line that's why she's
not going anywhere
Joe Biden is dangerously in this
territory consequently or were
coincidentally Joe Biden is blaming
Bernie Sanders as camp for these attacks
it is a little curious this first woman
who came out Lucy Flores is a member of
a pro Sanders campaign group our
revolution she's been a pro Sanders
activist for years now and she comes out
and she says oh yes the vice president
put his hands on my shoulders I've never
felt so unsafe oh my gosh it was
harrowing I'm going through PTSD because
the vice president gave like put his
hands on me on his on my shoulders
briefly when he was campaigning for me
which I asked him to do okay whatever it
sure seems like a political attack to me
now there's a second accuser this woman
from Connecticut says that then Vice
President Joe Biden touched her
inappropriately in a Greenwich
fundraiser in 2009 I'm so torn on this
because I the Democrats use this against
us all the time a second accuser all
these women that must be true
inappropriate touching she made him feel
like he made her feel uncomfortable so I
really want to use this against Joe
Biden but it's just not fair here's what
the woman says
from Connecticut she says quote it
wasn't sexual
but he did grab me by the head he put
his hand around my neck and pulled me in
to rub noses with me when he was pulling
me in I thought he was gonna kiss me on
the mouth what you thought he was gonna
kiss you on the mouth but it wasn't
sexual no what you're saying is
objectively this wasn't sexual but
subjectively I could misinterpret it to
appear to be sexual that's what she's
saying in that one sentence and what did
you do I'm sure Joe Biden does this all
the time
this is this whole thing I'm the I'm the
guy we're really close we're really good
friends I'm grandfatherly I love you so
much I love you if I were ten years
younger
uh haha wink wink smile smile vote for
me haha it's just an unctuous politician
by the way apparently his wife does this
too there's this photo of his wife
kissing jeff bezos on the mouth
not in some saucy you know car or in a
motel room or something she did it at a
podium at the White House because
they're the the Biden's are very
affectionate because they're that kind
of politician okay now there are a
couple other people who are coming out
and this same woman the same woman in
Connecticut said I never filed a
complaint to be honest because he was
the vice president I was a nobody
there's absolutely a line of decency
there's a line of respect crossing that
line is not grandfatherly
it's not cultural it's not affection its
sexism or misogyny misogyny means the
hatred of women you're telling me that
Joe Biden coming I'm saying I you're
great you're terrific that expresses a
hatred of women that it's the same thing
Joe Biden coming up to you and saying
I'll love ya honey and putting his hands
give me a little shoulder massage and an
abusive husband punching his wife's
lights out those are the same thing
that's what she's saying because these
women are obviously engaged in a
political hit job which is totally
baseless which is totally cynical which
is totally wrong to actual victims of
sexual violence
really
awful stuff and this is here's how you
know here's how you know that this woman
from Connecticut is a joke and a cynical
joke at that she ends her accusations
she says if Biden truly supports women
and gender equality he would step aside
and support one of the many talented and
qualified women running oh yeah it's
that right oh I did who knew it was that
easy this is extortion like the mob does
the meter movement has become just as
extortionist as any Mafia family in New
York say yeah you know that's that's a
really really nice campaign you got
there sure would be she would be a shame
if somebody accused you of being a
rapist
yeah no it's a night you've gotten a
really nice political career there well
sure it'd be a shame if you got me too I
tell you what we'll make us a little
deal you drop out of the race you
endorsed one of these very
well-qualified female candidates over
here and maybe we forget the whole thing
happen and you're a wonderful supporter
of women's equality how's that sound huh
and make a little deal
you scratch my back well you better not
scratch my back no more and I'll scratch
yours okay that's what they're doing
they're talking just like little
mobsters and so I'm I'm totally with Joe
in dismissing this this obvious attack
I'm not the only one by the way Whoopi
Goldberg agrees with me we'll get to
that in one second but first got to say
goodbye to Facebook and YouTube we have
so much more coming up we get a little
bit more into Joe we get a little bit
more into Trump and AOC in the green New
Deal we even get into National Poetry
Month but it's ten bucks a month $100
for an annual membership you get me you
get the Indra Clavin show you get the
bench bureau show you test questions in
the mailbag you get the Matt Walsh show
get your mailbag questions in that is
coming up tomorrow I believe is that
Wednesday already gosh the time just
flies when you're having fun when you're
drinking cough fa you will also get the
leftist here's tumblr this is what you
need oh the me to boomerang swings back
and it's knocking down the Democrats
best candidate for the general election
ha ha ha ha ha get the tumblr we'll be
right back with a lot more
politics makes for strange bedfellows as
we speak about modern love an apt phrase
I'm now defending Joe Biden and I'm
agreeing with Whoopi Goldberg who is
summing up this situation pretty well
responded that in all his years on the
campaign trail he's never believed he's
acted inappropriately so he'll listen
respectfully it's applause but it was
never his intention now should she have
spoken to him about this before she went
on television about it or I mean is it
you know in the old days we would call
Joe some folks of a certain age would
say he's a little overly familiar yeah
okay but most politicians when they're
you know doing this with you and you
know they are and Joe is Joe as a
hands-on kind of guy yeah yes but no one
I've never heard anyone and she says she
felt violated and I have to take her out
of word but it would have been nice if
she had turned him and said you know
what Jay I don't really like this so
please don't do this or not mr. vice
president I'm not really comfortable
with there's something because he's
standing right there so it's hard to say
to somebody who's somebody touches you
inappropriately exactly right whoopee
whoopee is exactly right joy behar is
exactly wrong cuz listen to that
disagreement there Whoopi says you know
if this woman is gonna wait however many
years and come out and say when Joe
Biden put his hands on my shoulders it
made me uncomfortable therefore he's
basically a rapist it might have been
nice to say in the moment hey mr. vice
president please don't touch me and then
I'm sure who said okay honey yeah I love
ya a vote for me vote for me okay that
would have been fine
it would have been nice to just say it
you know you're an adult you're a person
you're not just a delicate little flower
all the time right isn't this it's such
an irony with the feminist movement
we're told women are strong women are
capable women are are just as rational
and direct as men and then we're told oh
I could never sell tell someone my
feelings oh I could never buy know I
could never express my opinion no please
save me save me Bernie
ten years later or whatever she says
just go and just say hey man please
don't do that that's how adults deal
with things and what is Joy Behar say is
always that's so hard to do that's so
hard to say and whoopee doesn't let her
get away with it whoopee says no it's
not it's not hard to say hey look I got
a mouse
I got vocal cords I have a brain I can
turn my body to face him and say hey
please don't do that it's not hard it's
a very easy the the professional victim
crowd wants to pretend that you aw you
could never say that how can you expect
a rational human being to talk how could
you you couldn't expect that Whoopi's
right now there are two more women
coming out of the closet Katelyn Caruso
former college student said that at an
event mr. Joe Biden put his hand on her
thigh and then she squirmed a little to
show her discomfort and but he hugged
her just a little too long this was at
the University of Nevada at Las Vegas I
have no doubt that Joe Biden put his
hand on her thigh or on her leg or on
her knee or on her shoulder or wherever
but look she says in and I even squirmed
a little to show my discomfort here's
another way you can show your discomfort
hey please don't do that or move you can
also move you don't need to and I was so
clear to him I did this it was so quick
how could anyone misinterpret that that
I was calling him a rapist and telling
him to get away from me I practically
pulled out the pepper spray
I packed practically pulled out the bear
mace no you didn't you have to
articulate what you're thinking we're
not mind reader's you can't read
somebody's mind women can't read men's
minds men can't we read women's minds
that's why we have a language so that we
can speak or she could have just turned
away rather than squirming a little to
show her discomfort she could have said
or she could have even come out and said
I felt totally violated at the time but
she didn't she waited until it was
politically convenient till the one
minute that Joe Biden is about to
announce for president then all of a
sudden then the attack comes out another
person 59 year old DJ Hill
said that when she and her husband were
having her photo taken by Joe Biden
Biden put his hand on her shoulder and
then started dropping it down her back
which made her very uncomfortable again
that's a you problem
darling that's not a an objective issue
you're taking how do you take photos I
gotta say I'm a little uh I'm a little
sensitive to this because I have to take
photos all the time when I go to these
college campuses I take a hundred photos
every time and I actually joke sometimes
when we were taking a photo you know you
put your arms on somebody if they're
very short then you put their arms on
there on their shoulders if they're not
you put the arms on the back right
behind them and I joke I'll say okay
when we're getting ready for this photo
everybody stand forward I don't want to
accidentally touch somebody somewhere
and get me to haha
and then it's a joke and we make this
joke because of bogus accusations like
this how do you take a photo with
somebody you put your hand on their back
that's it that's every photo or I guess
you could have your hands at your sides
and maybe tit like it crossed over your
have them out in the other direction so
there's no chance you ever touch them no
you when you're taking a photo first of
all I don't think Joe Biden asked to
take a photo with 59 year-old DJ hill
something tells me 59 year-old DJ hill
asked to take a photo with the Vice
President and so he graciously says sure
and they're taking what is a familiar
photo and he puts his hand on her back
on her back he's not grabbing her took
us he's not reaching over grabbing your
chest no he's got his hand on her back
and she's it made me feel very
uncomfortable well that's a you problem
that's not a Joe Biden problem how about
and how about you say oh don't put your
hand on my back I have a very sensitive
back or whatever no you can I wonder I
mean this is such a frivolous attack on
Joe Biden I don't really care because I
don't like Joe Biden so it's fine if
it's gonna take him out whatever I mean
you know it's your primary guys I'm not
a Democrat I'm not voting in it you can
do whatever you want
dummies but I wonder how much of our
sexual culture that we're talking about
modern love all this weirdo bizarre
relationships between men and women
could be explained by Whoopi
Goldberg's advice could be explained by
this sort of political attack when I did
my blank book reasons to vote for
Democrats that was not the first blank
book ever there have been dozens of
blank books throughout history one of
the best-selling blank books sold a
million copies is called everything men
know about women and it's it's a great
book has a very similar content to my
book and I think that book is truer now
than ever I think they should rerelease
it it'll sell a zillion more copies
because this is not a normal way for men
and women to interact with each other
sexual difference is one of the greatest
things under the Sun it is one of the
reasons to get out of bed in the morning
coincidentally it's a reason to get into
bed as well so really it really
encompasses much of the here much of the
experience of the world but the way that
we're talking about it now does not does
not compute does not make any sense
we're talking about now cycles of egg
retrieval and transfer we're talking
about donated eggs we're talking about
all of these clinical things surrogacy
we're talking about that's how we're
primarily talking about it in the
culture we're talking about how
uncomfortable you feel if a guy that
you've asked to take a photo with put
his hand on your back we're talking
about how we can turn we now the joke
you see all these comedy sketches of
South Park did this too with PC
principal before a man and a woman are
gonna go you know go necking up on
lovers point they need to go get a
contract notarized saying I give my
consent to kiss somebody on the cheek
and I give this how clinical how inhuman
what an awful way to live how much of
the campus sexual crisis would be
explained by this there was an article
that came out about the hook-up culture
which is ubiquitous which it is
everywhere and basically everybody is
participating in it and they say it's it
is a little weird we get really really
drunk and then we go hook up with people
that we barely know and we all willingly
do it because we don't know how to
socialize we don't know how to relate to
one another I wonder how much of this is
caused by the lies that gender ideology
has sold to us that there's no
difference between the sex
there's no physical difference there's
no spiritual difference there's no
psychological difference it's all the
same and when we believe that live for
long enough we're in this bizarre place
where Whoopi Goldberg has to be the
voice of reason and say hey guys what if
you're having trouble communicating men
to what how about you just tell them
what you're thinking but you just tell
them what you're feeling a bizarre
sexual and modern love culture do we
have we have a little bit of time we can
get to Donald Trump's glorious showing
last night Donald Trump was giving a
presser on the green new deal on
Alexandria Ocasio cortes and most
importantly he says he's going to
postpone the Republican health care plan
until 2020 this has created a big uproar
because initially he said we've got the
best health care plan we're gonna give
you a great health care plan then he
backed off he said we're not gonna get
it done until 2020 this was a great idea
a very very good idea to postpone it if
they had been proposing it this would
become the central issue of the 2020
campaign and it's an issue that
Republicans lose on and why is health
care an issue that Republicans lose on
Donald Trump explains it well in this
address at the NRCC it should be easy
it'll be interesting to see but don't
underestimate the power of socialism to
get a vote it's what happens over a
10-year period when the country is
destroyed but they don't care about that
when they say we're going to give you
free education we're going to give you
free healthcare we're going to not have
you pay your loans for college we're
going to give you free everything
everything is free it's very seductive
to people it's not going to be so easy
like you think now in ten years it's
going to be easy when the country goes
to hell because that's what happens the
country goes to hell happened many times
look at Venezuela I mean this was the
richest country in that whole hem I mean
outside of us it was one of the richest
countries in the world
and now they have no food they have no
electric they have nothing
it's said never underestimate the
ability of socialism to get a vote this
is a per Ilion tin site that President
Trump is articulating this is why we
can't talk about health care before 2020
because what we are competing on is
they're saying hey we're gonna give you
everything for free and we're saying hey
you know commodities and goods and
services cost money and so there have
got to be balances and exchanges and if
you're gonna liberalize in this area and
if you're going to make this a little
more accessible to bring costs down
that's gonna limit care in this area and
this and then you're gonna lose on that
because you should never underestimate
the ability of socialism to get a vote
never underestimate someone says hey
everything is going to be free it's so
simple it's so clear we lose against
socialist policies when the policies are
vague and the socialist healthcare
policy from Democrats is vague they call
it Medicare for all why do they call it
Medicare for all because that phrase
tests very well Medicare oh that's nice
people get free health care and it's
people my grandmother likes it okay
Medicare for all what does medicare for
all really mean it means fully socialist
health care so when you start to explain
to people what Medicare for all means
how much it's going to cost them in
taxes however ones taxes are gonna go up
how it's going to reduce the quality of
care how it's going to reduce medical
innovation how it's going to ration care
by the government when you explain all
that to them the popularity of Medicare
for all plummets but when it's vague
when they're it's just vague which is
how it's going to be fought in the 2020
campaign it's very popular now
conversely we win when socialist
policies are specific this is why the
green New Deal is so beneficial to
Republicans and conservatives we love
aoc came out ALC is running away like
the little Roadrunner cartoon from the
green New Deal which she authored which
she person
only released which she personally
pushed which she personally made her
central issue which she personally got
all these Senate Democrats to co-sponsor
and endorse and then when that reality
sunk in now she's running away from it
everybody's running away from it because
when socialist policies are specific we
win president Trump identifies this
exactly right I'm only afraid that we're
going to be too hard or the green new
deal and they're not going to do it
because I want them to do it we don't
want to have them knock it out before we
get to run against it so let's take it
easy I'm actually saying it's a
wonderful thing the green new deal done
by a young bartender twenty nine years
old a young bartender wonderful young
woman that green new deal you know but
it's crazy you know the first time I
heard I said that's the craziest thing
you have senators that are professionals
that you guys know that have been there
for a long time white hair everything
perfect and they're standing behind her
and they're shaking they're petrified of
her we support the green New Deal how
about the woman from Hawaii the senator
from Hawaii
hi Lee nice woman right well I'm glad I
didn't say I'm gonna get great points
from my wife for not saying that but she
was so angry two men right remember
she's screaming at men and and then they
asked her about the green gnudi I love
it they said yeah but you don't allow
airplanes anymore so you can't get to
Hawaii oh we have to work on something
so somebody jokingly said we'll build a
train to Hawaii and she actually thought
it was a decent idea so now she supports
it cuz she thinks they're gonna build a
train go away but they really believe
this stuff and you know it's like it's
the craziest thing they believe it this
is President Trump at his best it's him
doing a stand-up set right this is this
is a guy who has grown up in show
business he has been a king of show
business and he is doing a stand-up set
he might as well get out there smoking a
cigarette with the one spotlight on him
in a stool it says so what's the deal
with this green new deal huh what's that
about how they're going to do it how the
senator from Hawaii
he says that she supports the green New
Deal it's gonna outlaw airplanes what's
she gonna do take a train back to
Washington yeah she's gonna take a train
back to washing that's a good idea
that's what they're gonna do am i right
he's he's treating it like a stand-up
set and I think this is admirable
because he is totally eviscerating the
green new deal here I mean this is we
talked about this with Joe Biden
this is the great fear is to become a
punchline you can be hated you can be
maligned they can call you Hitler that
is better than becoming a punchline and
the green new deal is a punchline aoc is
really in trouble right now because she
has become a punchline and she doesn't
see Donald Trump when they try to turn
him into a punchline he wins so it comes
back and beats them so he's not a
punchline if he had lost in 2016 he'd be
a punchline but he didn't he won so then
he became Hitler so then they call him a
Nazi then they call him a fascist and I
call him all manner of evil the green
New Deal's become a punchline because
the point he's making is that socialists
never have to answer for their terrible
policies because it takes ten years for
socialism to destroy a country maybe
even a little bit longer this is what
happened in Venezuela destroyed that
country and they never have to answer
the people who supported it in the first
place but when it gets really specific
you can drill down and you look at that
image that he gives you Donald Trump
does this all the time he creates these
great images Scott Adams talks about
this a lot that image you have in your
mind is mazie Hirono the senator from
Hawaii can't fly back to Washington so
she's gonna build a train now you picked
your train tracks going across the whole
Pacific Ocean from Hawaii to California
then she's just taken that train do it
to do it to do it now I support the
green New Deal what a great image in
your mind turns it into a total joke a
total stand-up set and he couldn't do
this stand-up act without the material
from the Democrats you can't just do it
you can't just try to be Trump
you can't just out Trump Trump that
isn't going to happen this it requires
this sort of material you know actually
al Sharpton made this point just that
you said you can't out Trump Trump and
you
right you know I think that one of the
important things taken off with Willie
said about tough tough enough take on
Trump you know as an old boxing fan I
learned don't fight the other guys fight
I think it's a big mistake to try to out
Trump Trump I think what you've got to
do is do your own fight plan and it will
trip Trump up I think some of the
mistakes that was made by the Republican
opponents in the Republican primaries is
they tried to go tit for tat with him
rather than raise the level of
discussion deal with the issues and
concerns of people talk over Trump
because what he's saying is nonsense and
if you make sense people will choose
something better clean glass it's always
gonna be chosen over a dirty glass if
you give them the app so he goes off on
his partisanship feel at the end but
he's right in the main point which is
that you can't out Trump Trump you can't
do somebody better than he does and I
think that's a lot of the appeal of
Alexandria cassio Cortez was oh she's
kind of like our Trump she gets a lot of
media as she's risks outrageous things
yeah she's gonna be our Trump you can't
out Trump Trump you can't win it at
someone else's game and that's what you
see here I mean this this green New Deal
debacle is a truly a catastrophe for her
I think it makes her a punchline I think
it basically ends this as an issue in
2020 they're gonna try to revive it but
it really hurts it and how does she come
back how does she she's now running away
from the policy she wrote she's blaming
it on a staffer she's telling senators
that they shouldn't vote for her policy
really tough thing the green new deal
and a great example of them we get
really specific on their policies we can
reckon because of the reality of it it's
a National Poetry Month and so because
we were talking about the green new deal
here at the end I just want to read a
very simple little poem from a great
poet named Joyce Kilmer he was killed in
World War one at the age of 31 so he
didn't have the ability to mature into a
really great poet but this is a popular
little poem and when conservatives talk
about the environment sometimes because
we want to show how wrong leftist
environmentalism is we I think
thoth would go too far or weasel cares
about the environment will destroy the
environment know the environment in its
natural place which is for us to enjoy
because it is part of God's creation
that's a good place for it and so this
is a poem called trees it was made into
a song and I believe 1948 or something
like that here's the poem I think that I
shall never see a poem lovely as a tree
a tree who's hungry mouth is pressed
against the sweet Earth's flowing breast
a tree that looks at God all day and
lifts her leafy arms to pray a tree that
may in summer wear a nest of Robins in
her hair upon whose bosom snow has lain
who intimately lives with rain poems are
made by fools like me but only God can
make a tree when we talk about the
environment this is the right idea we
look at it as part of the majesty of
creation as a way to look at that and
then look up toward the Creator when we
look at modern love this is an important
thing
poems are made by fools like me but only
God can make a tree when you look at the
natural order in all of its majesty it
is an awesome thing it fills you with
wonder and when you go in there and you
think you can do it better when you
think fools like us can do it all better
tinker all all of it around invert it
from what it really is you get two
really bizarre really morally chaotic
outcomes such as a grandmother giving
birth to her granddaughter with the
sperm of her gay son's lover and the egg
of her daughter modern love doo-doo-doo
all right that's our show tune in
tomorrow make sure you get your mailbag
questions and in the meantime I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael an
old show
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Robert Sterling executive producer
Jeremy Moore senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico
audio is mixed by Dylan case hair and
makeup is by Jesuit all Vera production
assistant Mick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show the Russian
collusion hoax has collapsed the
economy's doing well but Donald Trump's
approval ratings are stuck
why can't president the Donald get some
love we'll talk about it on the Andrew
Clavin show I'm Andrew Clavin